now the un says that cuts in british
overseas aid will have a devastating
effect on its work to reduce maternal
and child deaths around the world
the uk government has been accused of
reneging on its commitments
after cutting more than 80 percent of
funding to un agencies
for family planning and hiv prevention
well i'm joined now by former
international development secretary
andrew mitchell mr mitchell good to see
you on sky
news we've been getting a trickle
haven't we
of um information about where these cuts
are going to be felt from
what you know where do you think it will
be most acutely felt well it could be
most acutely felt in the poorest
parts of the world and what we are
seeing as
your report riley says is a devastating
85
cut in the family planning work that
britain has been right at the front of
of supporting and you know this does
mean that
250 000 avoidable
deaths among mothers and children will
now
go ahead it means that something like 14
14.6
million uh unwanted pregnancies will
take place
and it means that uh 4.3 million unsafe
abortions
will take place as well and this is a
terrible day
for british leadership in an area where
we are respected all around the world
for having made huge progress on the
rights
and protection of girls and women the
the result of this cut
will be a devastating have devastating
effect on the poorest parts of the world
but it's also breaking a promise that
the minister who is now responsible for
the planning for the glasgow cop
conference
on the floor of the united nations
general assembly he looked the world in
the eye and he said britain would
live up to these responsibilities to
help people in the poor world
and today britain is breaking that
promise and it's also breaking a
manifesto
commitment that all of us who were
elected to the house of commons just
over a
year ago signed up to that we would
stand by our commitments to the poorest
and we wouldn't balance the books on the
backs of the poor and that's exactly
what we're now doing
the rationale is the need to pay
for the unprecedented and unexpected
costs
of the pandemic do you have confidence
that it will be
restored as the prime minister says it
will be when it's fiscally prudent to do
so
well it's not true that it's an economic
measure you see the thing about the 0.7
is that it goes up or down with the
performance of our economy so
as our economy has shrunk significantly
in the last year so the 0.7 has already
gone down by 2.9
billion this further cut is not really
an economic decision no one believes
that it's a political decision because
the amount of money we're talking about
is just one percent of the borrowing
over the last year
and there would have been other ways of
making those economies but to take it
out of the budget spent on helping
some of the poorest and most desperate
people in the world
in my view is a shameful act and you
know people
notice in africa all around the world at
the united nations they notice
that britain in the past has been a
development superpower really driving
forward
this tackling of international poverty
and they see today that
britain has simply relinquished that
role
forgive me for interrupting even with
the cuts the uk
still remains one of the most generous
in the world in terms of aid
well i'm not sure that's true actually i
mean the germans have said that because
of the pandemic they will exceed the 0.7
next year the french are making it clear
that they will stand by the 0.7 the
american administration
is seeking 15 billion dollars of extra
money to help
the poorest in this pandemic and and
britain having promised
indeed enshrined it in law that they
would
stand by the 0.7 is now arbitrarily
without any vote in the house of commons
stopping the 0.7 changing the target
from 0.7 to 0.5
and you know there was a statement an
urgent question that i was granted by
the speaker in the house of commons on
monday and what was noticeable was that
40 members of parliament
from across the house of commons spoke
in that urgent question
virtually everyone condemned the
government for breaking this promise to
the poorest
and breaking this manifesto commitment
but
public support though this does seem to
be public support for reducing aid
during the pandemic well
it's true that in the red wall seats
apparently
according to a treasury minister 81 of
the
people in the red wall seats do not like
sending money overseas and
i respect that that view but what's very
interesting is that
according to other polling 94 people in
those red wall seats
do not think you should cut humanitarian
aid and
the way in which the budget is
configured means that we are
virtually only cutting humanitarian aid
because many of the long-term
programs are legally committed so it is
humanitarian aid
that britain is cutting and i mean
yesterday we learned that britain was
going to cut nearly
all of the water and sanitation and
hygiene project
you know we've been trained in britain
that in order to keep ourselves safe
one of the things we should do is to
wash our hands and for britain in the
heart of this pandemic
to be cutting this budget for the
poorest people in the world and
virtually wiping out that hygiene and
sanitation
budget is a terrible terrible shameful
thing to do
a final question mr mitchell um details
keep leaking out don't they how do you
think what's your view of how the
communications
of this have been handled by the
government
well you know the government has a lot
on its plate at the moment but but i
think it will be better to be up front
and to explain
the the decision the government has made
i emphasize without a voting comment
because they don't think they would
secure a victory in that vote
that we should be up front and explain
to people that these terrible decisions
are being made why they're being made
and in particular we should
make clear the government should make
clear precisely who they're going to hit
and be open and transparent andrew
mitchell good to talk to you this
evening thank you